madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer cinq morts et
un blessé dans une avalanche près
d'orcières merlette dans les
hautes-alpes on ne connaît pas encore
les raisons du drame
les députés examinent à partir
d'aujourd'hui une réforme des
prestations compensatoires ce système
avait provoqué des situations
dramatiques après certains divorces
l'abbé morel devant les assises de
l'aveyron depuis aujourd'hui il y est
jugé pour viols sur trois de ses anciens
élèves mineurs enfin pierre méhaignerie
bernard besson et jacques barrot
condamné à de la prison avec sursis dans
la sphère du financement occulte du cds
mais d'abord cet accident dramatique
très tôt ce matin sur l'autoroute entre
nancy et metz deux voitures se sont
percutées de plein fouet
cinq personnes ont été tuées dont un
couple et deux de ses enfants
c'est un conducteur qui roulait à
contresens qui est à l'origine du drame
un appel à témoins d'ailleurs été lancé
pour tenter de reconstituer les
circonstances exactes de l'accident
sonia mialhe alexandre dupont le choc
frontal a été d'une violence inouïe il
était 4h30 ce matin sur l'autoroute a31
entre métiers nancy lorsque le véhicule
qui roulait à contresens a percuté la
deuxième voiture ne laissa aucune chance
était cinq occupants de cette famille
qui partait en vacances il ne reste
aujourd'hui qu'un enfant de six ans
hospitalisée dans un état grave
les parents et deux des enfants sont
morts sur le coup tout comme le jeune
homme de 29 ans qui conduisait la
voiture folle pourquoi at il pris cette
autoroute à contresens pour les
gendarmes cela nous fait une personne
qui n'a pas pris conscience de 2,2
de l'accès d'une bretelle qui se
retrouvent en contre sens
mais bon là apparemment la personne
avait déjà circulé quand même plusieurs
kilomètres donc on ne peut pas
déterminer réellement la raison ce type
d'accident est bien plus fréquent qu'on
ne le pense en 99 sur les autoroutes
françaises
un accident mortel sur 20 est causée par
un véhicule roule en sens inverse soit
en marche arrière sans compter les
routes nationales à quatre voies pour la
prévention routière le principal
responsable
bref le conducteur et la parade bien
difficile à trouver aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de recherches sur des systèmes
de détection de ce type d'incident la
principale difficulté à résoudre c'est
qu'ils doivent être extrêmement rapide
puisque pratiquement il faut que
l'incident soit décelée en une minute et
la réaction en deux minutes c'est très
rare qu'un véhicule ont plus de deux
minutes à contresens sans percuter un
autre petite amélioration grâce aux
téléphones portables aujourd'hui l'
alerte se fait beaucoup plus rapidement
mais le danger reste entier après la
suisse et l'italie la france et donc à
son tour touchée par les avalanches une
coulée de neige a fait cinq morts et un
blessé
apr apic près d'orcières merlette dans
les hautes-alpes le drame s'est déroulé
hors du domaine skiable et pour des
raisons encore inconnues
reportage sur place de michel serhane
récit magali soeur c'est vers 15 heures
cet après midi que l' alerte a été
donnée par l'un des sept randonneurs
sorti indemne de l'avalanche
les skieurs partis ce matin de la petite
station de prat pics ont été fauchés par
une coulée de neige
elle se serait détaché à 200 mètres au
dessus du groupe six personnes ont été
emportées cinq sont décédées une est
grillé demande et je les ai vus comme
les autres oscillent en vue certains
avant et j'ai couru pour essayer de
mettre plus possible à l'abri et je suis
allé
l'avalanche s'est passé entre 5 et 10
mètres derrière moi et quand je me suis
retourné et d'avoir tout le temps que je
me retourne que j'allais me mettre à
l'abri bon la blanche était finie appelé
personne a répondu
le groupe était originaire de la région
il progressait sur une randonnée
difficile mais qui ne comportait pas de
risque particulier
mais aujourd'hui les événements nous
rappellent que la montagne reste malgré
tout un lieu dangereux parce que
et puis combien d'approché avec beaucoup
de prudence et malheureusement
aujourd'hui
préférez un seau et les randonneurs
disposaient d'un équipement qui a
balancé ce qui aurait permis de sauver
l'un d'entre eux l'enquète dira s'il
avait respecté toutes les mesures de
sécurité
et puis cette fois l'alpe d'huez un
jeune surfeur américain qui a déclenché
une avalanche dimanche dernier en
faisant du hors piste sera poursuivi
pour mise en danger d'autrui
il risque un an de prison et 100 mille
francs d'amendé le gouvernement
réunissait aujourd'hui un comité
national de sécurité sanitaire il a bien
sûr été question de la listériose
on se fabrique en deux langues deux
parents gelé font d'ailleurs
actuellement l'objet d'une enquête on a
aussi abordé le dossier de la vache
folle et contrairement aux états unis au
canada et au japon
la france a décidé de ne pas exclure des
dons du sang les personnes ayant
séjourné en grande bretagne le
gouvernement met en avant le fait que la
contamination par transfusion n'a jamais
été scientifiquement prouvé marc d'haene
à jean-pierre heckmann les soucis de
santé publique au gouvernement ont collé
ce matin au comité de sécurité sanitaire
on sait changer d'un bout à l'autre de
la table des dossiers plutôt brûlant
après la listériose place à la vache
folle
pas question de suivre l'exemple
d'autres pays industrialisés qui ont
décidé d'exclure de leurs dons les
personnes ayant séjourné durablement au
royaume uni selon le dernier rapport
d'experts pour l'instant une
contamination par le sang n'est pas
scientifiquement démontrée
pourtant on n'a pas encore prouvé le
contraire le risque est un risque
potentiel un risque virtuel qui n'est
pas prouvée alors c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire il
n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas de risque
mais il n'y a aucune preuve que le prion
soient véhiculés par le sang ni même par
des produits dérivés du sang plus on
veut réduire le risque d'exposition plus
il faudrait exclure de donneurs on va se
trouver confronté à un manque de
produits sanguins qui l'a cette fois ci
est un vrai risque en terme pour les
patients qui ont besoin de ces produits
sanguins
car exclure les personnes ayant séjourné
outre manche c'est perdre 5 à 10% de
donneurs est entraînée peut-être un
risque accru de contamination
elle du sida et de l'hépatite b pourtant
de nombreuses inconnues demeurent
l'association française des transfusés
condamne ce statu quo regrette un manque
de concertation et craint que des
informations ne soient dissimulées par
le gouvernement quant à celle des
hémophiles elle réclame une remise en
cause totale du système de prélèvement
français un des modes de sécurité
modernes la transfusion sanguine serait
probablement le don rémunérés
c'est une c'est une chose aussi qu'il
faut examiner pourquoi le don rémunérés
tout simplement parce qu'à ce moment là
les donneurs on connaît sont surveillés
médicalement et par conséquent on
connaît totalement leur origine selon
les connaissances actuelles les
probabilités de contamination par le
sang sont infimes il faut l'espérer dans
un pays
ancien champion du monde de la
consommation de boeuf britannique
une bonne nouvelle pour les personnes
âgées malades qui préfèrent rester chez
elles plutôt que d'être hospitalisée
hier la cnam et les syndicats de
médecins se sont en effet entendus sur
une revalorisation des honoraires
concernant ces visites un peu
particulière une décision qui satisfait
les médecins mais qui devrait aussi
permettre à la sécurité sociale de faire
des économies
martin n'a que jean laurent serra après
une matinée de consultation pour le
docteur albi c'est l'heure des visites à
domicile
en général elle n'en fait qu'une deux
par jours pas plus le cabinet où elle
travaille avec trois associés est ouvert
six jours par semaine et il est rarement
vide
selon ce médecin la charge de travail
est telle que sauf en cas d'urgence les
visites à domicile sont une perte de
temps pénalisante à la fois pour les
patients et pour le cabinet
quand vous vous déplacez vous passez au
moins un quart d'heure aller retour pour
les transports à pied une voiture
et donc c'est vrai que pour une
entreprise comme la cabinet médical de
travailler à son cabinet c'est quand
même plus rationnelle sur plan
strictement économique
willem à 85 ans madame rambo a subi de
multiples opérations suite à plusieurs
cancers
elle est toujours sous surveillance
médicale et c'est le docteur albi qui
assure les visites ce qui lui a permis
d'éviter de longues hospitalisations
pour le malade c'est très sécurisant du
cru prospective l'hospitalisation qui
est toujours quand même assez pénible
même des examens d'une journée moi je
suis fatigué ma tension le soir une
montée la caisse d'assurance maladie a
décidé d'augmenter de 60 francs le tarif
de ces visites auprès de personnes âgées
atteintes de maladies graves
une hausse importante le prix à payer
pour que les médecins retrouvent le
chemin de ces malades
je trouve que la sécurité sociale ne
remplirait pas son rôle et sa mission si
elle laissé au bord du chemin
une partie de la population qui n'aurait
plus que comme seul recours de partir en
établissement mais cette hausse ne
s'applique tant maison de retraite où
les médecins sont souvent attachés
l'établissement elle ne coûtera pas un
centime de plus aux malades puisqu'elle
ne concerne que les patients pris en
charge à 100% par la sécurité sociale
les députés planchent à partir de ce
soir sur une réforme des prestations
compensatoires accordé régulièrement en
cas de divorce et prestations qui était
jusqu alors donné avis devrait devenir
révisable notamment en cas de maladie de
chômage ou encore de remariage il faut
dire que le système avait abouti à des
situations dramatiques et tout ne sera
d'ailleurs pas régler à l'issue du débat
exemple avec le reportage d'élise galant
et benoît vers ans anne est veuve depuis
sept ans à la mort de son mari elle
hérite avec surprise de la prestation
compensatoire qui les verser à son ex
femme
les versements destinés à compenser la
perte de niveau de vie entraîné par le
divorce
en sept ans les revenus nan ne lui ont
jamais permis de régler les indemnités à
la précédente épouse celle ci lui
réclame toujours aujourd'hui
les trois cent mille francs à payer une
dette qui ne cesse d'empoisonner la vie
j'ai tout perdre et même une partie de
moi-même parce que depuis je ne saurais
plus je suis dépressive parce que je
suis en pleine inquiétude mais c'est dû
à quoi
à une loi qu'elle ait percé la situation
dan qui en change sa petite fille est
d'autant plus difficile qu'elle ne
perçoit pas la retraite de son mari
militaire de carrière
la pension de réversion estimé à plus de
10 mille francs mensuels est en effet
versé à la première épouse anne n'a
aujourd'hui droit à rien ce soir elle va
à l'assemblée nationale écouter la
réforme des prestations compensatoires
choqué que les députés ne veuille pas
annuler la transmissibilité
je suis au tây angoissé et puis bon j'ai
comme un nuage d'espoir j'ai dit
peut-être que ce soir ils vont changer
ils ont l'air un peu de conscience un
peu et qui vont changer à la dernière
minute
un changement qui est la seule solution
pour elle car si à 50 ans on est reparti
de zéro
travaillant comme agent d'entretien dans
une mairie après plusieurs contrats
emploi solidarité son salaire ne lui
permettra jamais d'honorer la dette dont
elle a hérité la nouvelle carte scolaire
a été révélée hier par le gouvernement
et claude allègre a notamment annoncé la
création de 350 postes d'enseignants
supplémentaires c'est beaucoup moins que
ce qu'espéraient les syndicats ou les
parents d'élèves mais certaines
académies sont mieux lotis que d'autres
dans le val d'oise par exemple les
circonstances imposent est un
renforcement des effectifs
réponse avec nathalie perez et laurence
ou la carte scolaire chaque année un
vrai casse tête pour les inspecteurs
d'académie pour obtenir du ministère des
postes supplémentaires
il faut d'abord enregistrer de nouvelles
inscriptions des lèvres mais il faut
également tenir compte du milieu plus il
est défavorisée plus l'effort sera mis
sur les moyens
exemple dans le val d'oise l'un des
départements les plus difficiles en
france 250 écoles sont en zone
d'éducation prioritaire et 75 % des
élèves sont issus de milieux pauvres
par exemple dans un département comme
celui ci a beaucoup d'enfants de nomades
faut que je prévois des postes aussi
pour scolariser les enfants des nomades
il ya beaucoup d'enfants primoarrivants
des enfants qui arrivent et qui ne parle
pas la langue
il faut que je pourrais moi aussi un
certain nombre de postes pour leur
donner les bases de la langue française
tout ça ça fait partie de la carte
scolaire
nous perdons des élèves et nous allons
avoir des postes
en dépit de cette perte d'élèves parce
que parce que le ministère veut faire un
effort particulier pour une population
qui est assez difficile des postes
supplémentaires occupés par des
enseignants venant d'autres départements
un redéploiement dénoncer chaque année
par les parents d'élèves et les
enseignants qui demandent de nouvelles
embauches
il fait que les budgets ne vote pas de
moyens nouveaux c'est le cas pour la
rentrée prochaine
l'administration a dit pierre pour et
pour déshabiller paul et donc il ya des
endroits où des moyens sont retirés sans
grande justification pour les donner à
d'autres où il y à davantage d'élèves à
prendre en charge donc c'est assez près
d'explosifs la carte scolaire
mais de son côté le ministère de
l'éducation affirme que depuis 91
il y à chaque année en france de moins
en moins d'élèves à la rentrée prochaine
il y en aura encore vingt mille ans mois
le nombre d'enseignants étant maintenues
on estime que cela fera 900 postes à
redéployer l'an prochain donc 900 postes
supplémentaires selon le ministère la
procès de l'abbé morel s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui aux assises de l'aveyron
l'ecclésiastique est accusé du viol et
d'agression sexuelle sur trois de ses
anciens élèves alors âgés de 10 à 13 ans
les faits avaient été dénoncés par
l'intermédiaire de lettres anonymes et
aujourd'hui l'accusé évoque une cabale
sur place hosanna la mission est
véritablement jean-lucien morel un
pédophile qui a violé et agressé
sexuellement trois de ses jeunes élèves
ou un minot sans victime d'une cabale 10
ans est lui destitué de son poste de
directeur d'école à mur-de-barrez à la
barre l'homme est clair poser minutieux
il a 71 ans souffre d'une maladie
cardiaque et nie en bloc tout ce qu'on
lui reproche
l'expert psychiatrique le présentera
comme un individu très intelligent sans
pathologie mentale mais avec quelques
traits de perversité un expert
psychiatrique qui s'expriment juste
après l'audition de la soeur du prévenu
prend l'a toujours soutenu et il n'est
pas question se tienne je sais quel
était votre jeu les copier nos enfants
des collèges
j'ai travaillé au collège avec lui ce
n'est rien n'allait pas couché sur le
banc de la partie civile deux enfants
ont assisté avec beaucoup d'attention à
cette première journée d'audience
vendredi avec un troisième mineur lui
témoigneront à huis clos bas ça ne
voulait croire de cet homme était
capable de faire une chose pareille et
bon c'était nous comme avec enfants qui
était menteur l'enfant qui était débile
tout tout tout on a vécu un calvaire et
je veux que tout le monde sache ce qu'on
a vécu parce qu'on était ridiculisé
d'une manière inimaginable ne s'est pas
retourné au commandant le procès j'ai
comme j'ai un sale injustice et je
demande que mon fils soit entendue et
que je passe tellement vite je pense à
tous ces enfants qui n'ont pas eu la
chance c'est un des attentats menés
aujourd'hui
d'ici là près de 90 témoins sont appelés
à la barre devant les trois family
season du jury de la cour d'assises de
robert politique et affaires et edith
cresson serait à son tour mis en cause
dans l'affairé elf d'après nos confrères
du monde une société fondée par l'ancien
premier ministre aurait reçu 3 millions
de francs d'une filiale du groupe
pétrolier
il s'agirait là encore de l'implantation
de la raffinerie alona en ex-allemagne
de l'est
et puis d'autre part les juges
d'instruction chargés de l'affairé elf
ont lancé aujourd'hui une commission
rogatoire internationale aux philippines
pour tenter de localiser alfred sirven
ex-numéro 2 d'elf en fuite depuis
maintenant trois ans les trois anciens
ministres du cds ont été condamnés
aujourd'hui à des peines de prison avec
sursis dans la sphère du financement
occulte
leur parti carmen youri jacques barrot
et bernard bosson qui devrait pourtant
bénéficié d'une amnistie immédiate
puisque les peines sont inférieures à
neuf mois de prison avec sursis
explication pierre didierjean bernard
hier pierre méhaignerie garde des sceaux
de 93 à 95 est le seul des trois anciens
ministres jugés pour le financement
illégal du cds à être revenue
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal alors de
la décision
jacques barrot ancien ministre du
travail dans le gouvernement juppé
bernard bosson qui fut ministre des
transports ne se sont pas déplacés les
trois hommes politiques centristes ainsi
que quatre autres prévenus étaient jugés
pour avoir financé leur parti par le
biais d'une caisse noire alimentée
depuis des comptes suisses l'instruction
avait établi que 25 millions de francs
au culte avait ainsi circulé mais la
plus grande partie de ces actes
délictueux été couverte par les lois
d'amnistié votée par le parlement en
matière de financement politique
finalement le tribunal a prononcé des
peines avec sursis inférieur ou égal à 8
mois donc tout à me stable compte tenu
de la remise en ordre du cds à laquelle
j'ai opéré
je trouve la décision du tribunal sévère
même si j'ai conscience qu'ils ont
volontairement choisi une peine amnistié
ce qui personnellement me réjouit c'est
que tout le monde est sur le même plan
monde aussi bien l'exécutant de bonne
foi votre serviteur que les chefs du
parti
tout le monde a été passé sur le même
plan s'il n'y a pas d'appel du parquet
dans le délai de dix jours
plus personne ne pourra jamais reprocher
niable sur france à murray n'y a aucun
des ministres ce qui vient d'être décidé
c'est terminé condamnation pour recel
d'abus de confiance
mais condamnation symbolique très
vraisemblablement effacé dans quelques
jours des casiers judiciaires
en revanche la miss qui ne couvrira pas
la condamnation au civil
les sept prévenus devront payer
solidairement 5 millions de francs à une
entreprise qui s'étaient portées parties
civiles
après avoir dû financer le parti
centriste jean-marie le pen déçu de son
mandat du conseil régional en provence
alpes côte d'azur le président du front
national avait été condamné je vous le
rappelle à un an d'inéligibilité
trois mois de prison avec sursis et 5000
francs d'amendé à la suite de son
altercation avec le maire socialiste de
manque la ville annette peulvast bergeal
manifestation aujourd'hui à paris des
intellectuels se sont mobilisés pour
dénoncer la situation en tchétchénie il
faut dire que depuis quelques jours les
témoignages d'exactions ou de torture se
multiplient aujourd'hui le gouvernement
français a même évoqué la possibilité
d'un arrêt de la coopération entre
l'union européenne et la russie pour
répondre à l'attitude de moscou qui
poursuit inlassablement son offensive et
justement aujourd'hui médecins du monde
fait état de nombreux témoignages tous
confirme l'extrême cruauté et
l'inhumanité des troupes russes
vis-à-vis des civils en tchétchénie un
rapport qui intervient le jour
anniversaire de la déportation des
tchétchènes par staline
il y à 56 ans isabelle sabouraud elle
réclame le départ des troupes russes
ces femmes réfugiées en ingouchie
commémore le triste anniversaire de la
déportation de leur peuple par staline
il y à 56 ans aujourd'hui poutine est au
pouvoir
et plus de 200 mille civils ont dû fuir
leur pays pour les tchétchènes
l'histoire se répète une date
anniversaire choisi par médecins du
monde pour dévoiler son rapport
il confirme les tortures pratiquées dans
ce camp de filtration dont le seul nom
évoque la terreur tcherno kosovo ici
sont détenus les personnes soupçonnées
d'avoir combattu au côté des
indépendantistes
mais contrairement à ce que semble
montrer ces images filmées par la
télévision russe
issus les coûts les viols sont monnaie
courante
le docteur dick hausse et a pu examiner
l'un des premiers rescapés de thierno
cochon
c'était 20 jours d'humiliation vient 20
jours de détention terribles et il nous
a raconté en effet tous tous qui
subissait au quotidien comme ses vices
comme il était battu
des conditions de vie absolument
épouvantable et puis cette espèce de
stress permanent de ne pas savoir si on
va être exécuté pour pour pour n'importe
quoi ou être déplacés vers une prison
encore plus terrible médecins du monde
confirme aussi le pilonnage systématique
des villages au sud selon des
témoignages plus de cent mille civils
fusillés par des mercenaires russes
autant de crimes dans l'indifférence
quasi générale
tous les témoignages que nous avons
montrent qu'il y à des crimes de guerre
pour le mois voire même par leur
caractère organisé et systématique des
crimes contre l'humanité ce rapport une
cinquantaine de pages pour exiger le
libre accès de l'aide humanitaire et
l'arrêt immédiat des violations des
droits de l'homme qui soliste au
quotidien dans ses dessins d'enfants
recueillis dans les camps de réfugiés
nombreuses manifestations aujourd'hui en
espagne au lendemain de l'attentât qui a
coûté la vie à un élu socialiste et à
son garde du corps
une explosion à la voiture piégée
attribué par les actes les enquêteurs à
le t1
les obsèques du député se sont déroulées
aujourd'hui à madrid en présence d'une
foule très importante
et puis dans de nombreuses villes des
centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblés silencieusement
c'était notamment le cas à vitoria
lieux du drame où le premier ministre
josé maria aznar s'est joint au cortège
les etats-unis sont accusés d'espionner
depuis des années les relations
économiques européennes
ils se serviraient pour cela d'un réseau
d'antennes prévu à l'origine pour
surveiller les soviétiques pendant la
guerre froide c'est un journaliste
indépendant britannique qui est à
l'origine de ces révélations il a
présenté aujourd'hui un rapport devant
les députés européens qui sont effarés
de l'ampleur du dispositif et de ses
méfaits
patrick esther pascal verre d'eau le hic
le moigne dans le nord de la
grande-bretagne
il est une base ultra secrète son nom ne
figure sur aucune carte
et pour cause depuis 50 ans elle sert à
espionner toutes les communications
radio électrique du monde construite par
les américains dans le climat de terreur
qui présidait durant la guerre froide
ces antennes et coûté jusqu'ici les
troupes soviétiques pour éviter que
d'éventuels observateurs ne puisse
savoir dans quelle direction sont
orientés les paraboles de réception
celles ci sont dissimulés sous de vastes
bulle de toile dehradun la station des
coupes de man with il emploie
aujourd'hui 2000 personnes pour les deux
tiers des américains
elle dépend directement du plus secret
des services secrets la msa l' agence
nationale de sécurité des états unis
l'installation est capable d'intercepter
3 milliards de communication par jour
communications téléphoniques fax ou
internet
ces antennes sont connectés à de très
puissants ordinateurs qui dispose en
mémoire d'un dictionnaire de mots clés à
chaque fois que l'un de ces mots clés
par exemple clinton intervient dans une
communication dans un fax ou un télex et
bien les ordinateurs vont enregistrer la
communication et vont la traiter
automatiquement sans que personne
n'intervienne
le réseau américano britannique baptisée
échelons possède six bases dans le monde
et comme écouter les russes ne présente
plus guère d'intérêt aujourd'hui les
américains ont reconverti leurs réseaux
en système d'espionnage industriel
ce qui leur a permis de remporter des
contrats commerciaux de façon déloyale
au détriment par exemple d'airbus
industrie ou de thomson c'est ce que
dakar nouvelle est venue expliquer ce
matin à la commission des libertés du
parlement européen
mais je pense que l'union européenne est
prête à lutter cela dépend à présent la
volonté conjointe de l'allemagne et de
la france
ouvrir le feu pour obtenir les
protections plus fort beaucoup de
députés européens l'angleterre serait
bel et bien le cheval de troie des
américains en europe apparemment il ya
une complicité claire entre le royaume
uni et les etats unis le royaume uni et
membre de l'union européenne que nous
sommes espionné par un 1 de nos amis moi
ça me dérange beaucoup
non le royaume uni n'a pas trahi
l'europe répondre à un peu trop
rapidement le prenons unis le système
échelon serait même déjà capable
d'écouter votre téléphone portable
nous sommes en train d'envisager de
déposer une plainte au pénal pour
violation de la vie privée
devant les tribunaux britanniques sont
en train d'examiner cette possibilité
nous avons peur
et si la commission denquête ce qui
serait fait ici n'aboutit pas j'espère
bien que les tribunaux britanniques
paient plus tard le tribunaux américains
dowd rhône suite sauvera le spla cet
après midi à paris elisabeth guigou a
confirmé que le problème était bien réel
et g il semble en effet que ce réseau
soit détournée à des fins d'espionnage
économique et de veille concurrentielle
et par conséquent ceci appelle de notre
part une particulière vigilance
les ministres européens
en débattront à bruxelles le 30 mars
tout fait l'actualité de votre région à
demain 19h30 pour soir
ah ah